I remember that judge said to me Mr
Brandon you're such an accomplished
painter why do you persist in doing
these forgery I'll say it's like this
when I see an old canvas I can't help it
I I've just I've got a knack of being
able to copy any subject doesn't matter
I've done Picasso I did a Picasso and I
couldn't even remember the guitar I
didn't know which way you would I did it
upside down apparently
[Music]
can you tell me where did you grow up
and what was your childhood like
um I grew up in Brighton in Buckingham
Road near the station first room was
mum's room where we live in my
half-sister stayed there back bedroom
with three of us all top to toe in the
bed you know that was it hardly any
blank it's a big army coat under bed it
was poverty there's a place in Brighton
called Warren farm and it was I spent
about two years in there we were back
and forwards to the home until finally
one day I think they'd had enough you
know they came to us and Mrs Gibson and
Mr Odin and brought us new clothes all
in Gray and said your boys would have to
take them it was like a care system you
were taking it
why is that just because your mom mum
had CB mum had a form of tuberculosis
because she worked in the laundry in the
30s and from The Damp sheets she got
this so so she just couldn't look after
us and that's what they used to do in
those days you had no choice just as to
take you away and that was it after that
they moved us around from one place to
another and that was the Holmes oh
incidentally Peggy Ridley bought me my
first set of oil paints and I started
oils it when I was six six and a half
just six just before I went into Dr
bernardo's to put these lovely paints
and I oh hours and hours doing
everything I even started a copy I was
copying the Constable for hay Wayne and
doing things that so I painted all my
life and when you get into bernardo's
system they encourage it they if I if it
hadn't been for bernardo's I don't know
where I'd have been I really don't know
but on the day I left on a November
night with one pound 50 or 10 Shillings
it no 30 Shillings in my pocket and I
actually ended up looking for jobs and I
saw this and Men wanted for circus this
is my circus days and the first guy that
came to me was a guy called Louie and he
went what do you want son I said you got
any job sir he said how old are you I
said you never it's heavy work this is I
said well I said I can do it he said I
don't think are you so skinny looking he
said no I'm sorry and I walked away and
he went come here if you ever worked
with elephants or in no he said come
with me so I walked in walked me across
this was winter course massive big
elephant tent and all the elephants are
all lined up and he said your job is to
look after these you'll be washing them
down and raking them out and cleaning
them that one day I was um I was
painting my day off and Dicky
chippyfield he said he said did you two
of those Max I went yeah said can you do
the sides of the trucks and the wagons
and do them surgery the Lions I said yes
so so I became part of the family and I
ended up with my own Caravan what was
the this turning point in your life when
you understood that art Fortune is a
thing and you can start doing that when
did I start forging yeah uh and I left
the circus I didn't think you're bad
enough I want to go to London right so
because I thought I want to paint you
know so but I you know before that I
arrived in London and ended up in
Shepherd's Bush and I was dosing I was
sleeping rough you know with all the
other doses but they looked after me I
couldn't afford new canvases so I
started buying old ones and uh I thought
I know what I do I saw a copy of a
Clarkson Stanfield and I thought I can
copy that on Old canvas aged up with tea
stains secret of what I was I was good
at was they represented reproducing the
colors of that day and the Aging I don't
know if you're too young to remember
what they're called bead glue it was a
glove Scotch glue it's called and you'd
use it in woodwork you place it in the
pan and that cold water leave it open
diet goes to a jelly next day you put it
on the heating and it comes to like a
liquid get your old painting
do it on there brush it over take it to
a heater but it can't be dry heat it's
got to be electric fire and you Circle
it like that go to the tap wash the B
group this is a water base you're left
with all the cracks empty your Hoover
out put it on the floor rub it all in
all the cracks are filled with crap old
glass on there in frame and Nails you've
got in the garden have been there for
six weeks tap them all in
don't you'd fool anybody because they
think how the hell does he get these
cracks on it and a guy came up to me who
was my sort of my father you figure his
name's Samuel Cohen and he looked at me
and he went hello Sonia said to peaches
he said how much is that shipping scene
I went 150 went it's a bit cheap it's a
good painting that where'd you get it
from I said well I'll just get him he
said come on tell me I said look I paint
them you went you paint these I went
yeah so he said tell you what he said
come and have a coffee me or drink a
wine and we'll talk about it they're so
going to meet Sammy Cohen and uh the
aging and the auctions all it all stem
from there then we we hit the auction
rooms big time really big time
can you talk me through that okay so
Sammy and I we used to go as father and
son like hello Dad and all that sort of
thing well you would be pretended that
we knew nothing about paintings first of
all we would go into the auction room
and say good morning sir and you go good
morning and he said uh I said would you
have a look at some smudges so I've got
and you guys yes of course so he said I
said Dad bring them in so he'd bring
these pictures in and he'd go we used to
sell a lot of bring a lot of crap
pictures rubbish and like we call Pot
boys like a lot of junkies to buy and
you'd throw in a goodie like a like a
Clarkson Stanfield and you go oh is that
on the floor there can have a look at
that your dad's pick that picture up and
you pick the pen you go yeah that's
quite nice it's quite a nice picture
while I'm talking Sammy would stop me
and they go you see son said this
gentleman really knows his business if
you study like what we're doing trying
to get his mind off what he's looking at
then it is to go into the auctions and
then it would be a wish to ring it but
we used to go to a preview you and stand
there next to the picture with our
brochure potentially potential buyers
and then we'd listen to the comments
right so think yeah he'd come out and
say yeah nice nice uh nice picture you
would have a go at that we'd look at him
and think right on the day of the
auction we would pick them all out and
think he's gonna have a go he's gonna
ever go and and Sami was on one side I'd
be the other we'd be we'd be ringing it
we'd be beating it up so I had my
certain sign I might even straighten the
tie or do something like that he would
so if when we when it got to about two
or three thousand we probably started to
sort of like be careful as you're going
to buy the value thing about yourself
and it started to bid up we got to five
and a half Grand a way out so we used to
do that right I'm out gone and that's
how the auction that somebody stood do
what would you say were the most famous
paintings you copied
I paint I copied everybody when you say
famous oh I've I hit a lot of galleries
in Bond Street but with lesser known
artists you know you don't walk around
with a Rembrandt or a Picasso or
something like that it's too good to be
true I mean Larry yeah I could do
Larry's but he was very popular he was a
vet in 68 he was not quite so well known
as his today but you know I was we used
to hit the auction rooms I mean I hit a
certain calorie for 80 000 in Pond
Street you know and that's what that's
what we were doing that we were hitting
big time that was a couple of Samuel
Palmers and they look good but you know
that was it we did lesser known by his
artists you know
can you tell me about Iranian Reggie
Craig how how are you painted your
mother this was strange one day I'd
already met Ronnie Cray's boyfriend on
the on Green Park you know the railings
with the paintings
he came up to me one day it was suited
in Period about my age he was he went
hello so he said do you do these smudges
like I said yes so do you ever do
portraits from photographs I went yes he
said uh he said where are you then we I
said well I'm at Portobello Road on
Saturday so he came down he went hello
so he said I've got his photograph he
said do you want could you do it and
it's the lack of a woman about about 50
or something like that so he said can
you do that smudge then I went yes he
said by next week I went yeah I can do
that for you so I went and did it and
came back with it and he went my mates
are up the road at a pub called The
Olive Lonsdale I think it was and they
he walked in front of me and I worked at
the back and uh I walked into the pub
and it was pretty darkish you know I
couldn't focus it was quite sunny
outside and I and I suddenly recognized
Reggie Reggie was sitting down Ronnie
was at the bar and Rodney came up to me
went hello son he said you got that
smudged and you've done it have you my
boy says you've done it went yeah he
said let's have a look then so I pulled
it out the bag like that and he it all
went quieter didn't like it and he went
he went Reggie have a look at his Reggie
ever look at his Reggie you really did
this son I went yes he said bloody
Marvis look at Reggie have a look he
went yeah cool that's mum look he's the
eyes are right aren't they sit down son
so I sat down
cry there cry there I'm in the bloody
middle I have a drink and I was going I
was so nervous especially if Ronnie you
know because there's something about him
and he went he went uh love it he said
how much are you then son and I was
going well you went and registered give
him a two I thought two quid 200 pounds
and 68 with a fortune and Ronnie put his
hand on my leg and he went and he's a
good looking kid and well he looks like
a pop star and yes I'm going out the
door he goes here he said max Maxi boy
you must come and have a team with my
mum in Valance Road I went I can't miss
her I've got to go to church on Sunday I
was out of that one crazy thing so that
was it
it's Quaver versatile scale to copy
different techniques and everything how
did you achieve that I I've just I've
got a neck of being able to copy any
subject doesn't matter I've done Picasso
I did a Picasso and I couldn't even
remember the guitar I didn't know which
way went up we did it upside down
apparently but so it didn't matter but
it I didn't know but but there are
nobody fakes today it's just because it
because of the the knowledge they have
the you know the the scientific in my
day they didn't have that you could get
away with it now they can even tell you
what day you painted it or or the color
you've used you know so you know now
it's it's too difficult you know I
wouldn't bother anyway
what was the point that got you into
prison
um well the first time I went into net
and uh I was tossing I ended up in
Dorchester
uh I was sleeping in the railway cut
truck and I got out one morning uh and I
thought right no food starving and I was
in Dorchester walked up the High Street
and thought hello uh don't I didn't eat
for two days I walked into this hotel
little guest outing and I saw a
chandelier so I nicked the chandelier
and a 100 day clock and wheeled it down
the High Street and just thought I could
sell it for food and then
somebody somebody at the station said
this guy just walked in you know wheeled
something in the baron they got me and I
I ended up in the magistrates court and
I refused to give them my address so
they gave me three months but as soon as
you get in Nick and they know you can
paint and draw your mate because they
respect you for who you are there and I
had a separate cell and I started my
drawing and I was my I was doing um old
drawings and dogs and pictures and
children for the for the old legs so I
got I became a tobacco Baron I was doing
a painting a drawing for some tobacco
there's an artist called Samuel Palmer
peninning drawings now Sammy used to
come to me on a visiting day now in
those days I was not high risk and I
used to sit on the table and Simon says
how you doing son are you finding it I
went no he said dear listener fancy
doing a bit of work here am I going to
do it here and send it by post he went
no he said up my sleeve I've got um six
sheets of old paper which he nicked in
the library used to go to the baby and
raise them out of the old books you know
and used to roll them up and I'd be
talking to him like that and he'd go
right and then he'd go and he said now
then do your time keep your head down
and you'll be out soon and and then you
would just slide out my sleeve now I'd
go back and I would say out Governor you
went okay then I said see you later dad
and I need to cut to myself put them in
my Bible and they'll knock out a Samuel
Palmer and pen and ink drawing and I
think right in my Bible and then don't
get about six together next visit three
weeks after you'd come along would you
go and I've done five for you I went
good lad so he used to do the same thing
roll them up in his sleeve so when I
came out I had a few Bob in the bank you
know so it was good they were going for
about 1500 quid that's the first time
winning Nick and after that I did three
stretches for a forgery I remember that
the judge said to me Mr Brandon you're
such an accomplished painter why do you
persist in doing these forgery I'll say
it's like this when I see an old canvas
I can't help you I just get a withdrawal
synth I've got a paint on the bugger and
I get that feeling now you know I I must
admit I miss the old days I really do
miss the old days
yeah so the other three times in prison
yeah have you spent a long time in there
what I did agencies I did an 18. a month
for forgery two semi apartments from the
greedy dealer called Otto who tried to
sell the people what the same paintings
in the same auction uh auctions how he
got me came back to me I got raided in
cricklewood came in a fraud Squad and of
course I've got two on the easel right
not finished and he went hello I said I
don't know anything about them sir
anyway Bank the rights gone so I've got
18 months on that one and then the other
time was uh I've got I've got an eight
month uh you know I've got an eighth
month for doing a yeah that was the same
sort of thing it was fake at the gallery
for the galleries got wise to me after a
while I didn't just do it in London I
did Manchester I did uh Canterbury I did
a nice big hit in Canterbury yeah
did you ever feel
about selling someone a a copy no and
honestly it was survival
I mean I felt sorry one day when I was
in the auction room and I did a Thomason
oh it was a good it was a Dutch winter
scene skating figures and it went up to
14
000 and it was a total fate but the
caves were so right it was perfect and
the guy came to me after a Persian guy
in a lovely suit he went I'm so sorry my
friend you did not get the picture I
said well Governor you win Sam you knew
samsa that's it but I did feel guilty I
do feel guilty sometimes you know it was
just it was just living surviving
because I've been ripped off so many
dealers and that sort of thing you know
you live on the edge I'm okay now I
don't money is is okay but I still love
meeting people I love all this I love
talking
um I do I love my bernardos I made a lot
of money I made 80 grand for barnardos
for you know auctions you know I met
Ollie Reed in one of my auctions so yeah
but what would you say your is your
favorite style to copy uh I did a
Caravaggio and I got it pretty damn
close to the original it's called the
taken of Christ if you know it there's
there's a there's Caravaggio there's the
Two Soldiers uh there's dividers there's
Jesus and Saint Peter I sold that you
know I know when I sold it I was
heartbroken because I didn't want to
sell it yeah I've got a Coolidge I've
got a Coolidge which the dog's playing
poker have you seen that I love it and I
don't I don't give them monkeys about
the money side of it I really don't if
any of you need a Banksy on your kitchen
door ring me up I'll come and do it I'll
Thrice
I'm gonna hold you to that
so we just showed them the film of what
we did and all the photographs and I
just remembered the security heads of
security just putting his head in his
hands and just over and over again
saying two million because they'd spent
two million pounds on the defenses and
and it was all for nothing in the face
of you know a cheeky scouser really